foreign
I've lived and worked in some very
diverse countries around the world
I was born in India but I grew up in
Iran
I remember I was about eight years old
as a child in Iran with my family
watching the beautiful Festival of
navrose
navrose is celebrated usually at night
with families gathered around a bonfire
they share food they sing songs
sometimes they even jump over the fire
for good luck
and I remember how deeply that reminded
me of another festival called Lori
celebrated all the way over in India
also with families gathered around a
bonfire sharing food singing songs
together
even an eight-year-old child can tell
how profoundly similar those two events
look in two sets of countries that are
culturally so different
like a kind of hidden connection
as an adult I spent 20 years of my life
studying consumers all over the world
what they feel what they believe in and
how they act upon those beliefs when
they buy things
and of course a big part of my job is to
truly understand the diversity that
exists in the world
but maybe because of my upbringing what
truly fascinates me is when we find
these hidden connections these secret
similarities between people where you
least expect them
today I want to share some of that magic
with you bring you into my world and we
are going to go do some detective work
on the world's consumers together
stay with me because I think there's a
message of Hope in here for all of us
before we start
about how
companies businesses are organized today
how they operate today
most commonly companies are organized by
regions sub-regions that's how Supply
chains organizations are set up
and if it's not geographies then it's
some other thumb rule it could be linked
to some common historic period so for
example the commonwealth countries it
could be linked to a common religious
roots for example I've been a part of a
lot of discussions on the Halal economy
it could be something anything that
allows us to put the world into neat
little boxes neat little clusters that
explain why people are similar or
different
but I've realized that when you study
the consumers and when you go deep
it's interesting how none of that
applies how wrong some of that thinking
can be let me show you
about a year ago a team of us set out to
understand how consumers exercise Choice
around the world
in this process we interacted with over
40 000 consumers in 18 countries around
the world
we asked them many many questions about
their mindsets to start with so for
example your world view your personal
philosophy do you feel optimistic do you
have a love for technology do you care
about peer approval things like that
but we also try to study some very
specific consumer Behavior so for
example what do you look for when you
buy a snack or you buy a beverage or
luxury products what needs are you
trying to fulfill
as you can imagine there was a ton of
data for the geek inside us to go crazy
with right I love that type of data so
anyway we take all that data and we
start to draw correlations we start
running all these analysis and we come
up with this kind of a proximity
analysis
quite simply every Green Dot represents
people of a particular country
the closer the Green Dot is to the map
in the middle the more similar the
mindsets are for those two sets of
countries and the further The Dot from
the map the more diverse the mindsets
for those countries it's as simple as
that
so of course when you do this for the US
you can see that the Canadians the
people of the UK and the Australians are
very similar in mindsets to the
Americans
now we had been studying consumers for a
long time and the whole team fully
expected that we were going to see a lot
of clusters come through based on some
of those thumb rules that I talked about
earlier
so imagine our surprise we run this data
and we find very little clustering based
on any of those thumb rules we didn't
for example find an Asian cult cluster
we didn't find a European cluster
nothing like it in fact we found 90
correlation between the Americans and
the Australians two sets of people on
the literal opposite ends of the world
can you think can you imagine that how
how amazing is that
and this is a big deal by the way
because businesses companies operate
govern themselves entirely on the basis
of these clusters that we found didn't
even exist
and believe me we tested a bunch of
thumb rules and the interesting part was
that it was not as if you can find new
thumb rules to replace the old ones that
don't work the answer was kind of
technical actually it was just don't do
it
resist the Earth to find any kind of
thumb rules to explain the world these
are only propagating stereotypes
so then we said okay if all these thumb
rules don't work how do you make sense
of all the diversity that we see around
us how we how do we put some patterns
how do we understand it
so then we started to study the specific
consumer Behavior I talked about what do
you look for when you buy insurance what
do you uh need when you buy beverages
when you buy apparel cars every things
like that
and here we found something that was
even more profound I think let me show
you
so this time I'm using China as the base
Market again as before Green Dots
overall mindsets
now you can see immediately when you see
this chart that the Chinese are such a
unique group of consumers
the inner circle is empty the second
circle is also empty then you start to
see India Mexico couple of other markets
but the correlation shows not a lot of
similarity between the Chinese and those
group of customers so clearly China
stands apart very unique group of
consumers by the way notice Japan on the
top left here the Japanese are so
diverse from the Chinese and yet I know
so many businesses that put Japan and
China as neighboring countries in the
north Asia cluster that's so common it's
so wrong anyway I digress I get very
excited with this stuff
so then coming back to the point on top
of it we overlaid these black dots the
black dots are now the needs when you
snack so what motivates you when you
reach out for a snack that's the black
dots
and when we did that and we studied it
we found a hidden connection I don't
know if you can already see it but I'm
gonna Circle it for you
we found that the Indonesians the Saudi
Arabians and consumers of the UAE snack
in very similar ways to the Chinese
let's think about it for a second these
are Muslim countries very different
culture very different background to the
Chinese and yet this snack in similar
ways how cool is that right
and similar how well for first in all
these countries snacking is a moment of
social Indulgence
it's it's something you do as a group so
people snack in groups
they they share the snacks they often
buy a hot snack that they purchase from
a hawker or a food court somebody
prepares it fresh for them the quality
is not guaranteed it's very important
they snack in similar ways in contrast
the Americans over on the top left snack
very differently Americans snack alone
they don't share their snacks it's it's
often at their desk in a package very
different from the rest of the countries
now I wonder do the Chinese and the
Indonesians know that they snack
similarly I seriously doubt that but for
a beautifully human thing to know right
and valuable too imagine what a Chinese
snacking company can do with this
Insight a lot right
let's take you to another one I'll show
you another one
still stayed with China the green dots
are still the mindsets but this time the
black dots are how you buy cars what you
look for when you buy an automotive
product
now again
I guess you guys are getting it better
with this now but here's the hidden
connections
we found and I'll name a few countries
there's quite a few similar to China but
two that I'll call out
South Africans and Nigerians buy cars
with similar motivations as the Chinese
in all these countries your car your
ride is a status symbol it tells your
peer group who you are so your car needs
to show you've arrived in life and it's
a very external point of influence what
will others think if I drive this
particular vehicle
in contrast look at the Germans at the
bottom very different very internal very
personal your car has to be fun to drive
that's very very important and who
blames them right with those beautiful
autobahns lovely roads no speed limits
of course you want your car to be a fun
ride right
but wait look at the French now the
French are very different from the
Germans they want their cars to be
reliable to navigate narrow roads
so there you have it two countries
France and Germany neighboring countries
European countries very different
motivations and then a couple of African
countries similar to the Chinese and the
way they buy cars no clustering no
business group will ever put these
countries together but maybe a road trip
from Beijing to Lagos is just going to
do the trick who knows
anyway one more last one indulge me just
to rub it in
so here's another one we're coming back
to the US this time again green is the
mindset but the black this time is how
you buy clothing apparel
now remember we talked about how the
Americans and the Canadians are very
similar in mindsets earlier
and we also talked about uh you know of
course they are closely connected
neighbors as well
now however they don't buy a paddle the
same way the Americans buy things that
are on Trend they're looking to indulge
the Canadians look for utility they are
looking for apparel that can be good for
adventure and a love of outdoor sports
is critical here
but controversially the Russians by
Apparel in very similar way to the
Americans also looking for something
that's on Trend also looking to indulge
now to say that they've been tensions
between these two countries is a serious
understatement right and yet they have
this one beautiful connection they have
one thing in common
what a lovely idea right
now I could go on and on I showed you
just a few examples today but we found
this over and over again category by
category country Pair by country pair we
saw this in all kinds of things like
luxury beverages Insurance you name it
we found these connections everywhere
and I don't mean any of this to belittle
the massive beautiful diversity that we
see in consumers around us that's
exactly why consumers are such an
important study for people like me
but I think this work shows that mankind
is connected in a profound way that we
never imagined
it also shows that these connections
defy any stereotypes that you and I
or businesses can come up with these are
patterns where you least expect them
and in these connections of course there
are commercial opportunities for
marketeers who can Embrace this Insight
of course it's commercially valuable
but today I want to go a step further if
you permit me
I think in these connections there's
also a message of Hope for the world
we live in a world that has globalized
for more than four decades
and yet we're getting torn apart shaped
by the geopolitics of our time countries
are falling into blocks fault lines are
appearing everywhere
I'm not a specialist in geopolitics I'm
just a student of the consumer
but when I look at this data and I think
about it if only people knew that we are
similar in the most profound ways in
some of our most everyday activities in
The Way We Sip a cup of coffee taste a
snack try on a new outfit or test drive
a car how beautiful would that be maybe
if we knew that we would also learn to
understand and empathize with each other
it's a lovely thought to reflect on
maybe with your next cup of coffee thank
you so much
[Applause]